how is it possible that you read a
screenplay what 50 times before you
shoot it yeah so when I get a you know
my perspective on
directing is I'm trying to be the
authority on the material and most of
the things that I do that are you know
in the feature or short space I've
written or I've been part I've been a
part of that process from the beginning
I've given notes from the beginning I'm
aware of all of the kind of mental
gymnastics that are behind those you
know 10 pages or those 120 pages and so
when I get a script for TV
because I haven't been privy or had the
privilege of seeing that process
I'm trying to get
a very thorough understanding of what's
on the page so I can begin to
deconstruct what I think that process
may have been
so that means I'm reading the script as
many times as I can in as many different
environments as I can
um I'm reading the script as different
crew people
um this is just my personal
um
take I like to read it as the
cinematographer I like to read it as the
Wardrobe costume designer I like to read
it as the production designer because
then
and I read it as a director last because
I feel like
all of those things help me get into the
mind of
um a the people I'm collaborating with
but like B I get an understanding of
what I have at my disposal as the
Director so I could read a scene in on
the third reading maybe I'm like oh you
know what now I'm thinking about it as
the actor because I've done all the
other thinking and I'm like oh what if
the actor wants to sit down
um in this scene well I'd love for them
to have a chaise lounge uh versus like a
chair you know so now you know that
third reading revealed a Furniture
selection you know what I mean
um or if I'm reading at home versus
reading at a cafe when the world was
open like that
um sometimes just being around a bunch
of people changes what I'm digesting so
um it's important for me to do that I
also make a spreadsheet where I take all
the story lines and this comes from
another book on directing I'll take all
the story lines and put them in a
different column so I can have a
top-down look at the architecture of the
entire episode
and it also doubles as a brief refresher
for me on set should I need it or if an
actor is like you know well where was I
in the last scene and I'll be like oh
well that was what doing Scene 40 now
but in scene 22 you did XYZ and then
they can be like okay great I know where
I'm coming from
so
um again being as thorough as possible
is the is the is the goal
interesting so you would digest a script
differently in let's say a busy coffee
shop here in La than you would let's say
in a library yeah
and I think it's just it's kind of hard
to
explain with any
value that's not like
it just feels different but like you
know you you might be paying more
attention
in one of those you know settings that
you had in another or maybe you heard
something in the background that
triggered a subconscious thought about
something you're experiencing here I
don't know yeah I can't put it I can't
put like a thumb on it or
point to what it is exactly but I do
think I know for sure like I've it's
been
on subsequent readings where something
is revealed
um and so I'm trying to
really give myself as many opportunities
to find out find those Revelations
before I'm on set
and as the Director lasts you where the
director's hat reading it last that's
interesting because I feel like I can't
I have to I have to I'm I can only
direct something that's been figured out
like otherwise like I'm I'm putting
camera in random places that are not
driven by actor or like some other level
of like thematic thought that is
Tethered to story you know because I
mean I could I could very easily be like
oh yeah I put the camera here I'll do
that that uh we will swoop around but
then like you know as you read it you're
like I'm gonna treat that storyline like
this actually and
I have to I have to settle into it a
little bit more
do you ask the screenwriter for story a
b story C story or how many story lines
are in the episode
I
when I get the script I I extract them
myself I try and identify them
um as you know oh the a story is
um
you know this character is
having a crisis of confidence about
something at home and then the B story
is this thing at work and then the C
story is
one of the kids is going through XYZ and
then the d-store you know and I'm sure
sometimes I'm probably maybe adding a
storyline you know because I might I
might really carve them out uh to be
distinctive but maybe in their mind
something is
a similar storyline you know but uh yeah
just go in and carve it out and when I I
have time I'll try and
give each scene a name
um now I have less and less at that time
now but I try and give each scene a name
so I'm like as I step into directing
it's like this is you know uh
so-and-so's retribution or you know
whatever it might be so I can kind of
have a guiding principle for how I'm
talking about the scene to the actors or
the crew how I want to shoot it and just
have a you know something that's helping
me make have a point of view because at
the end of the day I think
I'm there to apply in a point of view
and a point to apply a point of view
from which to
shoot and direct the scene
right because we were talking about
inventing Anna um before we when we were
setting up and so I guess you could say
well you know we're learning about this
journalist and she's there and she
doesn't want to do another me too story
she wants to do something else and she's
in war with her editor
and she's just fascinated by this the
story of this woman
and she's having a crisis at home I
guess I don't know if she's going to
have a baby or she's trying to or
something and she's not even sure she
wants to right and then she just becomes
obsessed with this woman almost as a way
to avoid her own life really in a lot of
ways so yeah that's those are basically
the three stories and I'm sure there's
other parts to it but yeah that's right
you had me thinking of that just because
yeah in different episodes there were
probably other characters where I was
like and this is the D story and this is
the E you know because some other
supporting character was important to
because there's always it's always this
point Counterpoint to whatever the theme
is it's like here is you know this idea
represented at its best via this
character and here's this idea
represented at its you know perhaps
worst through this character and
the cocktail of the entire episode
hopefully says
and here's what we think about that
right and maybe that's when she meets
the other people that knew Anna right
okay that makes sense yeah now I see
what you're talking about how do you
figure out how many story lines
are in an episode
um yeah I mean it's just carving them
out as I so I mean like functionally
like as I read the script and this is
well
this is probably into
you know
second or third reading like the first
one is I try and let that be
uninterrupted and purely as a reader
um so I can kind of just say oh okay
here's the story you know that it's is
being told I don't want to start saying
like oh that's funny oh that's witty or
you know making notes on I think that's
a high angle shot like I just want to
read it uninterrupted but second or
third episode I'll go through and when
making that spreadsheet you know first
scene is usually what the episode's
about right so okay boom I'll take that
second scene
um I'll just go scene by scene until all
of the
until I and and as and as a new
storyline is introduced I'll give it a
new heading
more often than not I don't think you're
going to get out of act one
without having been introduced to all of
them
you know and so and it's in television
and some of the
some of the shows will
um
literally tell you this is the cold open
this is act one end of act one
Others May do
dip to Black you know which is basically
the same thing
um and so you know like in in that
act one or you know in that first area
of scenes before it dips to Black that's
probably going to be all of the story
lines that are at play because it moves
so quickly that you're not likely to
have a new storyline introduced in Act
2.
so you haven't like an Excel document
already sort of like plugged in and then
you just for each new project you just
plug okay interesting
and so you do that fairly soon after
you've read the script a few times I'll
do that fairly soon
um you know like I mentioned it's useful
for being on set but it's also useful in
prep because in prep
I'm out on I'm in the van or I'm
self-driving and we're going to all
these different locations and now
instead of having to thumb through the
script I can go to my spreadsheet and
say oh yeah okay this is that scene
though and then on a location scout I
can glance really quickly remind myself
of why we're here you know and what what
we need and then
move through the process pretty
efficiently
okay and this is going to be different
than a shot list yes much different okay
yeah yeah do you do anything that's more
tangible that's not on the iPad or your
laptop
um no you know the the driver before
covid I used to have I used to have a
script and I would have the shot list
that I would print out from Hollywood
shot designer
and that would be a function of getting
the floor plans from you know that I
mean that I can show you
um
that would be a function
of getting the floor plans
from
resume editing
yeah that would be a function of getting
the floor plans from the production
designer uh and then implementing them
into
Hollywood shop designer and then
blocking it so as an example
um
this is a floor plan from a location a
club location
um
in West Adams for a scene from insecure
and this was uh three
characters
walking up to a club
uh and I'm sorry two characters walking
up to a club uh
Issa and Daniel she's blue he's red
um they find a bouncer at the door
bouncer one and bouncer two are our gray
folks and then we had
um another character
um I didn't put the name here but that
she knew from high school who walks up
and helps get them into the club
and so you know I've got
um I don't necessarily put everything in
here but I'm you know I at least have
the broad Strokes
um I had this wide from across the
street that tracked with them as they
walked past the line of people thinking
that they would walk up and get in of
course they don't and they get they're
met with security
um I think this wide from
uh it says why from across symmetrical
tighter for crowd exit that was
something that I got at the end of the
night it was for the end of the sequence
but I got it
you know you shoot all the exteriors at
one time and then uh
I knew I would have I would bring them
back on this Steadicam shot in the green
landing and over
the bouncer back to them and then I
would have you know coverage and then
coverage going both ways and so in the
in the pre-covered days I would have
these all printed out
um
and I would have my script printed out
and I would just kind of walk around
with all of these I'd share those with
the ad and with the DP and obviously
things change you know some scenes go
exactly as planned but it's mostly to
have a plan and to be able to have the
crew prep towards an idea because even
if the coverage all changes this is more
this is where the actors are going to be
um and so uh
but with covid in the beginning there
was a commitment to not to being
paperless to not handing like when when
people were watching their mail you know
like it was uh uh no Productions were
handing out scripts so everything became
um electronic and so another app that I
use scriptation became my go-to and so
it's great because the script's in there
now I don't have to have a script I can
update new drafts with my notes from a
prior script and instead of having that
app I showed you Hollywood shop designer
I would just add a page
into the script
take a screenshot of the plan and just
draw on it in the script so then
everything just became one document
and so that's called shot Lister that's
called Hollywood shot designer shot
designer I'm sorry and um so you can
kind of just plug in the exact sort of
what that you said Issa Ray was read her
character right and then the the other
character was blue and then gray were
the friends and stuff so you can assign
the sort of the yeah there's a bunch of
like icons for characters they have
lights they have different props they
have cars and motorcycles and kind of
all the basic things that would pop up
and you can just say you know and if you
want you can animate the cameras but at
a certain point you know I I feel like
it becomes a little too much because
you'll figure you have to leave room to
figure it out on the day but it's a
great device for prep so people can have
an idea of where the production should
be leaning and so and everybody gets a
copy of that uh well in this case the DP
and ad because they're filtering it out
to you know the camera department and
then the ad is
uh it's helpful for the ad to be able to
manage how much time will be needed for
a particular scene
but actors and backgrounds I mean I
might show it to them if they wanted to
but overwhelmingly
um
comes down to the communication which is
the again like the tough part of the job
like you know being able to relay what
you want being able to do it in a way
where you're not
um a dictator you know and you like you
like in my mind I've got this whole
scene figured out because I I can't show
up without having done that now it
doesn't mean I'm right but I've got it
all figured out and I've got to allow
the actors and the cinematographer
everybody to have their time to
find it and also feel collaborative in
it and so it's like finding out finding
developing the methods to do that
you know
that's the journey I think of the
director